ladies and gentlemen
parties here actually the party is
right here at madame tussauds new york
in times square
in the form of my guest co-host miss
snooki
yes hey girl because she's making her
formal return
to jersey shore family vacation this
thursday on
mtv but the big question snooki what
made you want to come back to the show
i just needed a break in general just
because i feel like it got really heavy
with the drama
but then the producers texted me and
they were like listen we're throwing a
party for mike for his sobriety
i was like i can't miss that and they
were like okay the baby showers and
giving me all these events
i was like all right i have to come back
i'm willing to shoot as much as i can i
just can't be away from my kids
for more than like three days were there
other reasons as to why you left the
show
i just wanted to be home in my jammies
and like just snuggle with my babies
so in general i just feel like i needed
a break for my soul
because i was like i don't want to be
here right now so i feel like it was a
good break
we saw the drama unfold after the speech
you and the gals gave at angelina's
wedding
i think this is it yeah it's not fun
angelina was so upset and then i felt
bad and then it just snowballed into
like more
drama it's like you can't handle this
like i'm not a confrontational person i
don't like drama
so um yeah i was i cried myself to sleep
for a couple nights
does the marriage last between angelina
and chris i'm asking that question every
single day well
it's like they're good and they're not
good so we'll never know we yeah
we'll never know the situation in lauren
they are the newest of the crew to
welcome
a child it's only been a few weeks but
how is fatherhood
treating the sich these days how's he
doing he's
he's uh i don't want to say confused
he's like
wait am i ever gonna get sleep yeah he's
adjusting to being a new parent and he's
like it's a lot but they're so in love
baby romeo is so cute yeah do we know if
he's changing diapers these days
i feel like he is yeah i feel like he
rather not
but he's doing the role okay now you are
on to another show with mtv as well
messiness so why are you the perfect
toast snookie
i'm the perfect host of messiness
because i am a hot mess
it's like ridiculousness but messiness
all about people getting drunk in videos
falling down you've definitely had those
moments yeah peeing in bushes
um so it's literally my whole life on a
show
you